on top of all the things that this
series represents
it is the first first round series
that lebron james has lost in his career
alfonso mckinney will shoot by the way
we have just been told that booker was
not ejected initially
it looked as if he were going to be
ejected only crowder was
regardless that's it that's why booker's
still on the bench
can celebrate with his teammates season
high 47.
he hit eight threes and the phoenix suns
have gone
on the road after missing the playoffs
for 11 consecutive years
and beaten the defending champion on
their home court
in the first round and now
they'll take on the denver nuggets in
round two
and that should be a beauty well it
doesn't get much easier at all but give
credit to the suns as you said 11 years
ago
lost to this same franchise the lakers
in a game six getting back in the
postseason
beating the defending champions
advancing
giving got to give credit to monty
williams the foundation the culture he's
established
and this team is on its way to meet a
worthy opponent in the denver nuggets
phoenix has now won 44 of their last
58 games there's jason kidd talking
with chris paul two of the greatest
point guards in the history of the nba
and chris paul
has taken his team to the second round
phoenix the number two seed has beaten
the seven seed
los angeles lakers four games to two
and obviously for the lakers injuries
and
frustration a fantastic run they've had
in last year's bubble this year
not the ending they would have wanted
but certainly a great team and
they rest and recover and a.d and lebron
come back next year but
this phoenix suns team dangerous booker
the way he's played chris paul if he can
get healthy aiden the confidence of
bridges and johnson overall play great
team effort
but you have a superstar right here in
the making in devon booker and
it was on display here particularly in
the first half of this game
if you're joining us late anthony davis
gave it a shot tonight he started played
about five and a half minutes and it
just
wasn't gonna go came up lame
the groin strain the hyper-extended knee
it was too much for the seven-time
all-star
to deal with chris paul
tonight played 29 minutes eight points
12 assists two rebounds but grant you
pointed this out in the fourth quarter
when they needed him to do a lot feed
the ball on drives
hit shots on the fly he answered it
exactly when they needed it
because the lakers were making a little
bit of a push and kevin he struggled a
bit but he made the right plays at the
right time
you know he had that injury but chris
paul sensational for his team
when they needed him what a spectacular
night for the rising star
all-star devin booker with 47 who is
standing by with our chris haynes
devin it was over a decade since the
suns
got to the playoffs you guys take down
the defending champs
how gratifying was it to face them
to feed them and now be on the way to
advancing
yeah that's the only way we wanted it to
be honest you know we knew we weren't
going to get to where we want to go
without going through them
um and it happened to be in the first
round so you know it was a tough
tough matchup all the way through you
know once they got us down 2-1 we had to
re
regroup and get everything right um and
we came in and we battled
you've been a guy that people didn't get
to see during this time of the year
how much did you want this moment want
this time for you to show everybody
what you do on a national scale i mean
i've been working my whole life for this
moment
you know what i'm saying you know so it
wasn't time to shy away from it
um you know plenty hours of you know
sacrificing you know a lot a lot of life
you know to this sport you know to this
game um you know so i wanted to put it
on full display tonight
your second round opponent is going to
be the denver nuggets
what are your initial thoughts of that
matchup they're tough
you know they're playing hard um they
played a great series versus
portland um obviously the head of the
snake jokage you know having an mvp type
year
and it's going to be a battle and we
understand that going into it but
appreciate you appreciate it
all right that is going to be a war with
the denver nuggets and the phoenix suns
in round two
special thanks tonight to reggie king
and statistician brian taylor our
producer
jeff randall